less than 24 hours after what appeared
to be a major diplomatic breakthrough
cruise missiles smashed into the port of
odessa
as fires raged pro-russian groups
circulated this video claiming it showed
a strike on a military target
but the attack is according to ukraine
another example of why the kremlin can't
be trusted on a deal to ship grain
through russia's naval blockade of the
black sea
[Music]
um
while ukraine accuses russia of already
violating the agreement
u.n secretary general antonio gutierrez
who called the deal a beacon of hope
when he attended the signing in istanbul
condemned the attack unequivocally
whilst u.s diplomats called it
outrageous
the initiative did appear to be a rare
win for diplomacy but whether it can
still be implemented remains unclear
the grain deal is effectively a very
focused ceasefire but for ceasefires to
work they rely
on i suppose what you could call a
golden rule and that is there must be
trust but that was obviously in short
supply before because russia and ukraine
are locked in a brutal war but the
attack on the port of odessa makes it
even more difficult for what was touted
as a landmark agreement
to get off the grounds
under the agreement odessa is not exempt
from hostilities only the parts of the
port needed for the export of grain
but the strike at the very least is seen
here as an act of bad faith
he doesn't want this deal because he
wants to take these millions of hundreds
of millions of people who are now
starving uh as a hostages he's food
terrorists he's terroristic at different
things but also as a food terrorist he's
weaponizing food
it will also enormously complicate the
plan which is already logistically
difficult and reliant on commercial
shipping and insurers to get the grain
moving in the black sea
and if the millions of tons of food
stuck here aren't soon shifted from
these silos
a global food crisis in which tens of
millions of people are already facing
acute hunger
will only get worse
alex rossi sky news
denite pro